hey check out her shoe cam just like the
ladies on the red carpet who makes my
shoe NYU Medical Center welcome to a
special Oscars edition of melatonin
movie reviews where I take
over-the-counter completely legal and
not have it forming melatonin and then
review movies I'm Ella Tony and this is
my roommates Alan Siskel if something is
wrong with her says take one to fall
asleep so I take four to stay awake now
here's the best Oscars rundown you're
gonna get without doing a Google search
Christian Bale's accent the hook it's
like when you meet a guy at a bar you go
home with them next morning here I'm
talk for the first time and it's like
you're from Boston if I had known I
wouldn't William Dafoe Willem Dafoe it's
not a name it's either William or its
will.i.am anyway who Richard II grant if
I wanted to hear a middle-aged do get
all keyed up on coke and talk about
books I'll just call my dad Raman Malik
is like that guy that you like until he
starts telling you I'll be like C's
musical notes as colors
rami malek teeth hope they were in Sag
they're doing a lot of work more
Herschel Ali's performance pretty good
considering he had to act opposite Sly
Stallone not a conspiracy theorist but I
do believe that Brad Cooper and Lady
gaga are cheating on each other with
their spouses oh my eyes are closed that
break I whipped up this unbuttered toast
totally awful no seasoning cuts the
inside of your mouth and that's an honor
Green Book Best Actress Best Supporting
Actress as usual a tight race Lady gaga
losing to Glenn Close reminded me when I
was nominated for homecoming queen in
high school but I found out it was a
prank actually a teacher won that year
this is a second nomination for Melissa
McCarthy but the first movie where she
didn't have to hurl her body into a
fence jumping in defenses like I love
that that's good film to me Meryl Streep
is nominated didn't do any movies but
you know what it's tradition and my dad
for Mellet soda and never talk I just
like don't know how you feel
Keira Knightley in the favorite no she's
definitely in it yes I get the rule that
she was born to play yes anyhow if it
comes down at Emma Stone and Rachel
Weisz for the favors like apples and
oranges same thing she's gotta
put some makeup on but in my opinion the
best actors this year was my
sister-in-law for sticking it out for
the sake of the kids snack break so in
honor of Vice i roasted this pheasant
which is with dick cheney was hunting
one shot that kind of face I love you're
learning I'm a war criminal the big
story with best pictures that this year
the movies are finally ones that people
have actually seen what the hell was
shaped like water I'm sorry which of
these movies is a spike Lee joint
I forgot what Klansmen okay I see that
what Klansmen mansion Carla Pizza Romo
was made entirely of black and white
footage that Fonzie Corazon found at a
Brooklyn thrift shop the favorite it was
shot on a GoPro which is awesome I used
to have a GoPro but got some of my
friends skatepark was just not awesome
he's not my friend anymore Bohemian
Rhapsody a wide step and so in my
opinion Black Panther is the best movie
and it should win I thought we discussed
why you shouldn't do that
haters say that an action franchise
can't win best pic but do you remember
this parade of trolls that movie was
garbage so bad I actually took my cousin
for his birthday and I made him pay me
back for the tickets so the Oscars don't
have a host it is Panera Bread and it
runs itself so now you know literally
everything there is snow and you can
finally when you're off his Oscars cool
enjoy the Oscars
tune in next week when I tell you
everything you need to know about the
Academy Awards
[Music]
just happy
you